sie sprechen davon dass olaf scholz
jetzt der große planer und macher wäre
bei der spd ich habe nur gesehen dass
die spd olaf scholz nicht mal ihren
vorsitzenden haben wollen würde und ich
frage mich schon inwiefern olaf scholz
jetzt nicht vielleicht auch einfach eine
marionette ist zum schluss von linkeren
parteimitgliedern wie saskia smi norbert
walter borjans oder auch einem kevin
kühnert und wie sehr er seine ideen
überhaupt umsetzen kann wenn die
parteien nicht mal als vorsitzenden
haben möchte ihnen jetzt vielleicht als
kanzlerkandidaten vorschickt und man ja
auch gerade im team gedanken bei der spd
wirklich gar nicht erkennen kann weil
man seine leute lieber zurück behält um
den leuten keine angst zu machen sagt
diese eigentlich die beide haben sie
jetzt tief in die klischees der der cdu
gegriffen und ich würde mal sagen bei
der bei dem zustand aber ist der stress
und leid bei den zustand und die
zerstrittenheit der union brauchen wir
jetzt glaube ich von der seite keine
ratschläge die spd ist sehr geschlossen
und das geht von saskia esken über
norbert walter borjans bisschen zu kevin
kühnert wir haben sehr gemeinsam diese
kanzlerkandidatur von olaf scholz
unterstützt und es gab wahrscheinlich
noch nie eine phase in der eine partei
so geschlossen über einen langen
zeitraum gesagt hat das ist unser
programm wir stehen gemeinsam ja nicht
nur zum kandidaten sondern auch zu dem
regierungsprogramm sie stehen gemeinsam
auf der bühne herrscht wie wir sie
gerade sehen würde dass ich das ist es
ist alt hier aber tatsächlich in diesem
wahlkampf das fällt ja jedem auftrag
hatte sieht also der spd tut doch
eigentlich alles um so zu tun als wäre
die spd in olaf scholz habe ihn kühl hat
sagt seit langer zeit gar nichts saß
carsten ist irgendwie abgetaucht
die spd immer wieder so und laut ece im
moment die union kopiert und die union
in diesem wahlkampf mit ihren eigenen
waffen schlägt die union hat in
wahlkämpfen auch immer so getan als sei
die union merkel weil merkel die
popularitätswerte hat und olaf scholz
versucht sich im moment als legitimer
nachfolger von merkel zu präsentieren
und so wie sie sprechen und so wie sie
auch über urlaub deutsch sprechen ist
das genau die strategie und das ist eine
strategie die aufgeht das kann man in
einem wahlkampf zu machen
nichtsdestotrotz ist natürlich das was
hinter olaf scholz steht sind wirklich
auch noch mal andere leute saskia esken
hat noch im april gesagt dass sie ein
linksbündnis für progressive hält als
eine ampel dass norbert walter borjans
hat laut darüber nachgedacht ob man
angesichts der umfragewerte überhaupt
noch einen kanzlerkandidaten braucht so
ist das und auch kevin kühnert ist
natürlich ganz klar der viel einfluss
hat in der partei linker flügel und
sollte die spd tatsächlich ins
kanzleramt einziehen der sich werden
sich auch wieder risse in der spd auf
tun ich glaube dafür muss man noch nicht
mal als politisch besonders beschlagen
sein um das zu wissen nichtsdestotrotz
haben sie vollkommen recht gibt es eine
disziplin in der spd die ich in 29
jahren als berichterstatterin auch noch
nicht erlebt habe also eine so lange
phase der anschluss erklärung dafür
anbieten warum das jetzt so ist in der
zeit in der viele sich über die
kanzlerkandidaturen gestritten haben bei
den grünen bei der cdu hat die spd die
zeit genutzt einen gemeinsamen plan für
deutschland zu entwickeln und hinter
diesen plan stehen alle das ist ja etwas
was zu wenig auch beachtet wird dass
hinter dieser geschlossenheit auch eine
geschlossenheit in die höhe halten steht
und deswegen trägt das auch und ich
haben in hamburg die erfahrung mit olaf
scholz gemacht er ist ein sehr starker
regierungschef in hamburg gewesen und er
hat die kraft die dinge auch zu
integrieren wenn es schwierig wird und
deswegen glaube ich dass das sehr gut
funktionieren wird und diese lange phase
in der wir uns auf den plan für
deutschland konzentriert haben dies gar
nicht so was ist immer ein ja weil weil
wir haben wochenlang zwischen server und
laschet und und und auch bei den grünen
alles verfolgt wie die
personalentscheidung getroffen werden
jetzt kriegen wir dreieinhalb wochen vor
dem wahltermin von der cdu noch im klima
programm vorgelegt bei uns das alles
sehr sehr fundiert erarbeitet worden und
das ist die grundlage für diese
geschlossenheit die wir jetzt auch im
wahlkampf sein es gibt ja es gibt ja
auch ich weiß schon also da haben sie
recht es gibt den langen masterplan
zumindest im kopf von olaf scholz ich
erinnere mich an dieses buch hoffnungs
land glaube ich heißt dass wir als zwei
drei jahre da saßen wir hier in dieser
sendung unterstand fast alles exakt so
drin bis jetzt auch im wahlprogramm
steht inklusive 12 euro mindestlohn usw
das war damals ganz bemerkenswerte und
wer das nächste er versteht auch was von
anfang an offensichtlich sein plan war
nur an einem punkt ist der plan nicht
klar und vom winter hat es gerade kurz
angedeutet hat schön schafft die frage
nach der linkspartei
warum klären sie das nicht warum wollen
sie dieses thema nicht ab warum schließt
olaf scholz eine koalition mit der
linkspartei nicht aus weil er gesagt hat
diese dieses topfschlagen wir anders
nennt vor der wahl werden ansagen
gemacht mit wem man auf keinen fall
verliert und redet das ist etwas was ich
aus seiner sicht und auch aus meiner
sicht
nicht nicht das ist nicht die politische
erfahrung dass das die diese ansagen am
ende
auch realität werden man wird diese
entscheidung darüber wer am ende mit wem
regiert zunächst einmal den wählerinnen
und wählern überlassen am 26 und danach
wird es sehr darauf ankommen mit welcher
bereitschaft die parteien dann wirklich
in die koalitionsverhandlungen gehen und
eins ist sicher sie würde es auch mit
der links einheiten einfach sich ja wenn
olaf scholz sowie das sich jetzt
abzeichnet den regierungsauftrag
bekommen weil er als stärkste bier als
stärkste kraft dass dieser weiter
vorgehen dann wird oder scholz dafür
sorgen dass auf jeden fall eine
koalition und einen regierungswechsel
vertrag zustande kommt der dem
entspricht was wir in diesem wahlkampf
sagt und da kann es menschen geben die
haben sorge dass die linkspartei
plötzlich mit irgendetwas um die ecke
kommt was dann ihnen nicht recht ist
aber dafür steht eben olaf scholz das
was auch immer nach der wahl passiert
den plan den er für deutschland hat
entspricht und dazu gehört ganz sicher
dass wir eine ein klares
außenpolitisches bekenntnis bekommen zur
nato zu den sicherheitsrat das haben sie
doch nicht dass die politik sie haben da
sind klare bekenntnis zur nato haben sie
doch gar nicht tschentscher wir haben es
auf jeden fall eigentlich meine von der
linkspartei das haben sie doch dadurch
entscheidet sich dann auch diese frage
können sie es doch gleich sagen er hat
es doch gesagt er hat die werden das
gesagt er wird dieses bekenntnis im
koalitionsvertrag haben und das wird
nicht nur ein lippenbekenntnis sein
sondern es wird eine ehrliche
positionierung werden und damit setzt er
den den rahmen in dem sich deutschland
auf inferno er sagte im grunde auf gar
keinen fall mache ich es mit denen und
sagt dennoch nicht nein warum macht er
das dann an den erwerber platz da sogar
deutlich klarer formuliert ich frage
mich auch warum er es nicht tut weil
eigentlich ist es ja gar nicht mal wenn
wir jetzt darüber reden dass scholz ja
anscheinend seinen eigenen plan haben
sollen was ich ehrlich gesagt nicht
abnehme aufgrund des personals was auch
in der spd hinter olaf scholz steht
warum sagt ihr dass nämlich weil es ist
doch nicht ist es doch nicht seine
politik eigentlich eine rot grün rote
regierung zu machen mit der außenpolitik
die wir sehen und sie zeigen damit auch
überhaupt keine transparenz wir in der
cdu sind gerade sehr transparent wir
unser team aufgestellt ist während die
spd ihre leute versteckt hinter olaf
scholz olaf scholz versucht sich als
merkel zu generieren merkel hat heute
einmal ganz ganz klar gesagt dass der
große unterschied zwischen ihr und olaf
scholz ist dass sie niemals überhaupt
auf die idee kommen würde ein bündnis
einzugehen daneben ist heute rennt ist
das eine große lust haben über diese
koalitionsfragen über die psychologie
was hat wer im schilde sehr gerne
sprechen weil es am ende ja davon
ablenkt dass wir harte themen haben sie
haben den mindestlohn sind nathalie
vision blox weg ist wir haben den
mindestlohn von 12 euro angesprochen wir
haben die sicherung der renten kürzen
aber wir wären jetzt mal ganz kurz über
die nato wir reden kurz über prinzipien
wir reden was die sahne dafür waren sie
sagten gerade ist ungefähr drei minuten
her aus erfahrung macht man sowas nicht
nur die erfahrung ist eine andere olaf
scholz war arbeitsminister und hat das
ausgeschlossen 2008 hat gesagt mit
keiner partei haben wir so große
differenzen mit der linkspartei auf gar
keinen fall hat 2010 als spitzenkandidat
in hamburg das gleiche bündnis abermals
ausgeschlossen das ist auch deshalb
nicht mit dem gewesen weil die
linkspartei ja nicht in hamburg und in
brandenburg und in einer körperlich
vorpommern und in der bundespolitik
immer dieselbe partei ist sondern wir
sehen dass zum beispiel in brandenburg
das in mecklenburg vorpommern über viele
jahre rot rote koalition sehr sehr
verlässlich und im interesse der bürger
die bürger auch reagiert haben und
deswegen kann man jetzt nicht sagen es
gibt eine eine grundkonstellation und da
schließe ich dieses oder jenes auswahl
ja jede frage nach einer koalition die
übernimmt die nächste frage schon wieder
auslöst und am ende haben wir nur noch
über koalitionen und ob man das glaubt
kann und aus dass deswegen werden sie
auch jetzt wieder aktiv wenn wir über
diese punkte reden und mein interesse
ist eigentlich dass wir über den plan
für deutschland sprechen und uns darauf
verlassen können dass olaf scholz als
ein sehr starker ein vertrauenswürdiger
kanzler dieses land die nächsten vier
jahre gut regieren wird wenn ich in
welcher politischen konstellation auch
immer ein dass entscheidend wählerinnen
und wählern schließt es auch heute nicht
wenn zb
eine rot grüne option ergänzt wird durch
die fdp zum beispiel das ist ein sehr
nah liegen des bündnis aber das
entscheidet nicht olaf scholz vor der
wahl und auch ich nicht sondern das
entscheidet zunächst einmal die
wählerinnen und wähler und dann die fdp
ob sie diesem bündnis zum beispiel ihre
unterstützung gibt wenn das werk eine
anmerkung dazu machen da warum ich
glaube dass die spd das nicht
ausschließlich halte ein rot-rot-grünes
bündnis für sehr sehr sehr sehr
unwahrscheinlich solange die option
offen ist kann man immer muss man immer
noch damit rechnen dass es doch sein
könnte aber deshalb glaube ich auch dass
die rote socken kampagne der union die
jetzt gestartet worden es nicht
unbedingt verfängt es gibt zwei gründe
warum die spd das offen hält der eine
ist ein strategischer wenn nämlich die
wahl so ausgehen sollte wie uns die
umfragen dass jetzt zeigen gibt es vier
verschiedene
koalitionsmöglichkeiten und sollte
scholz vorne stehen könnte immer noch
sagen liebe fdp oder liebe cdu ihr müsst
jetzt unter meiner kanzlerschaft in
einem bündnis kommen weil sonst sind wir
gezwungen dieses linksbündnis zu machen
das ist also eine strategische option
dass man das einfach als druckmittel in
der hand behält und dann gibt es zudem
ein parteitagsbeschluss der spd von 2013
bei 2013 bei der bundestagswahl gab es
nämlich die theoretische option das
linksbündnis zu machen und die spd-basis
fand das überhaupt nicht gut dass die
spd damals in die große koalition
gegangen ist und dann parteitag leipzig
wurde das eben ausgeschlossen und die
beinfreiheit hat nämlich olaf scholz in
der spd nicht dass er das einfach
abräumen könnte es gibt natürlich starke
kräfte in der spd sie ist das durchaus
wünschen so ein linksbündnis auch wenn
olaf scholz selbstverständlich nicht
dazu gehört also auf bundesebene
schließen sie auf jeden fall eine
koalition mit der linkspartei nicht aus
ich möchte mich zu diesen koalitions
diskussion eigentlich gar nicht äußern
ich möchte gerne über die über die
position sprechen franken konnte sehen
dass ich diese frage habe und dass viele
wählerinnen und wähler hat es schon all
ist die daran gefallen haben und
da stehen wir aber das ist nicht mein
eindruck mein eindruck ist dass die
menschen sich jetzt überlegen wen wollen
wir eigentlich an der spitze der
deutschen bundesregierung sehen das ist
viele etwas was viele leute sehr sehr
interessiert und deswegen ist das ist
das ein trailer seht euch wer 70 am
kabinettstisch wer wer fahren sollen
damit fängt aber davon hängt es hängt
sehr viel davon ab wer die stärkste
politische kraft wird und wer dann ja
denen die den führungsanspruch für diese
für diese bundesregierung für sich
beanspruchen kann und sobald es olaf
scholz ist sind diese ganzen roten
socken überlegungen und dieses jetzt
kommen wir so heimlich auf so an
das was ich für kommunistischen umsturz
planen das ist doch alles abhängig wer
olaf scholz kennt der weiß dass er ein
sehr pragmatischer ein verlässlicher da
möchte dass nur er möchte das nicht ich
weiß dass er das nicht möchte warum
sieht was irgend etwas interessieren sie
dann noch mich interessiert warum was
nicht sagt tschentscher und sie genauso
sie machen brauchen wir eine menge leute
in der spd die möchten dass alle wir
sprechen jetzt schon wieder eine stunde
über eine interessante frage der ethik
sie haben eine interessante streitigen
ich die bewegung der sonne lacht wir
reden über was ganz prinzipiell ist
nicht arithmetik der arithmetik ist was
anderes da geht es jetzt mal um
prinzipien
ja das prinzip lautet jetzt ist war
gerinnen und bürger haben die
entscheidungen darüber wem sie dieses
land an vertrauen ja danach wird sich
sie haben's grad eingeblendet werden
dass unterschiedlichste
koalitionsoptionen wenn es doch so viele
möglichkeiten gibt dann könnte man auch
die linkspartei einfach ausschließen und
sie wollen wir jetzt so drei vier kreuze
machen dass das kommt nicht in frage und
hab mich nicht ich bin mit so sind sie
nicht in der lage eine vernünftige
verhandlung zum beispiel über eine ampel
koalition zu führen okay weil sie weil
sie jetzt geht ums taktieren sie wollen
nicht die geisel von christian lindner
werden ich glaube nicht dass wir mit
einem starken wahlergebnis geisel
anderer dennoch haben sie kann ich noch
es war dagegen genau deswegen sind wir
jetzt auch endlich die geisel wird ist
ja wir bleiben jetzt bei diesen plan für
deutschland den sie entworfen haben ich
finde es sehr überzeugend wie olaf
scholz bei seinem kurs bleibt wie er den
auch dann diesen preis auch treu bleibt
wenn andere mittlerweile dann
übereinander herfallen wir haben in
diesem trailer auch wortgefechte
zwischen frau berbalk und herren laschet
erlebt und er bleibt in seiner rolle zu
sagen mein plan steht ich erkläre das
was ich vorhabe für dieses land und ich
sage zu dass nach einer wahl mit mir als
kanzler dieser plan im vordergrund steht
das hat er auch in dem trio klipp und
klar ja hat gesagt ich möchte das nicht
ohne es wirklich zu lage steht es steht
im regierungs koalitionsprogramm und das
ist auch so gemeint hat er zu den
inhaltlichen fragen
sich sich geäußert die mit der
linkspartei zu tun haben in der in der
linkspartei ein arbeitskreis 6 kennen
sie im bundestag nein
des bundestags und kennen diese da
sitzen da sitzen ein paar interessante
leute ich hab mir das noch mal angeguckt
da sitzen leute beispielsweise wie heike
hänsel die hat auf dem parteitag vor
zwei jahren gegen den us putschversuch
in venezuela demonstriert da sitzt
andrej hunko de hat sich mit mit moskau
treuen separatisten in der ost ukraine
fotografieren lassen und da sitzt auch
alexander neu von dem selbst in der
eigenen partei gesagt wird der erzählt
immer am tag danach was am tag vorher
die pressemitteilung des kreml ja solche
läufer saßen da hier werden auf ein
regierungsbündnis an dem und stolz der
kanzler ist werden keinen einfluss haben
das sind doch da sind wir mal sicher
okay also nein
sie können jetzt noch drei anläufe
nehmen und ich ist doch gar nicht meine
aufgabe hier noch mal eine neue
koalitionsoptionen ansage zu machen ich
finde es sehr wohltuend dass scholz
nicht konzentriert auf seinen plan auf
seine botschaften und ich finde es
tatsächlich müßig weil wir immer wieder
erlebt haben auf landes- und auf
bundesebene dass dinge ausgeschlossen
werden und am ende haben
haben cdu fdp und grüne monate lang
verharren das hat martin schulz internen
wahl gefragt hätte ich hätte gekostet
war ja ausgeschlossen hat am
kabinettstisch vertreten ist von der
lasten sondern es war gefragt hätten ob
wir eine große koalition eingeht da
hätte doch jeder sozialdemokrat und
sozialdemokraten gesagt nein auf keinen
fall wir wollen keine große koalition
nehmen sodann wird monatelang verhandelt
und das ist doch dann auch ein versagen
der anderen parteien gewesen wo die spd
dann doch wieder in dieses in dieses
bündnis gegangen ist und sie können
solche diskussionen und entwicklungen
vor einer wahl nicht vorhersagen
deswegen brauchen wir die
verlässlichkeit der kandidatinnen und
kandidaten von olaf scholz ist der
verlässlichste politiker den mir in den
letzten 30 jahren begegnet ist und wenn
er sagt es gibt klare politische
prinzipien die in einer regierung in der
ich kanzler bin eingehalten werden dann
kann sich da ganz deutschland darauf
verlassen dass glaube ich ich hab das
auch hier schon in der sendung mehrfach
gesagt olaf scholz ist in jedem fall ein
profi und einer der die dinge wirklich
bis zu ende durch denkt das weiß ich
alles und deswegen wunder ich mich umso
mehr dass wir in einer so fragilen
situation auch dieses landes an einem
wochen wächst an dem wir gerade stehen
daneben es auch um wirklich große themen
geht dann so so so prinzipielle dinge
nicht einfach mal klären und ehrlich
gesagt ist die sehnsucht frau quadbeck
ist es ist nicht da der frust im moment
so zu spüren die sehnsucht nach jemandem
der einfach sagt was auch ohne rücksicht
auf verluste ich sage euch jetzt was
meine fünf wichtigsten punkte sind das
sind meine überzeugungen das ist das
wofür stehe und wenn das nicht geht dann
sage ich euch ist das mit mir auch nicht
zu machen ich glaube ja dass ein
politiker der nicht nur taktisch agiert
und deswegen bin ich da auch so dran
sondern einfach klar und geradeaus
spricht wofür wirklich steht wird er
hatte eine echte chance also dieses bunt
gescheckte bild was wir hier sehen von
den wahlumfragen und von den
koalitionsmöglichkeiten das zeigt ja
dass die wählerinnen und wähler in
deutschland im moment noch in einer
gewissen weise orientierungslos sind
allen ist inzwischen klar dass merkel
dann wenn die neue regierung gebildet
ist nicht mehr da ist und die deutschen
schwanken im moment dazwischen dass sie
tatsächlich dass so ein bisschen
wechselstimmung und wände in der luft
liegt und auf der anderen seite nach
corona und der flut will man auch viel
sicherheit haben und im grunde genommen
das haben was eigentlich immer merkels
stärke war nämlich dass die ganzen
internationalen krisen und und so weiter
unseren alltag nicht so stark berühren
das war ja das was merkel immer
geschafft hat das von der von der
bevölkerung fern zu halten was
sicherlich auch ein geheimnis ihres
kollegen wann immer ich schrieb mal es
geschafft hat die leute im wesentlichen
nicht mit politik zu belästigen und die
kandidaten die wir sehen die die
schwanken dazwischen also vor allen
dingen eben die von union und spd dass
sie eben diesen dieses diese eigenschaft
von merkel dann fortsetzen wollen und
keiner ist so keiner hat den mut
wirklich zu sagen wo es lang geht und
auch selbst bei den grünen das ist
inzwischen so dass sie das was sie
eigentlich an herten zum beispiel für
den klimaschutz in ihrem wahlprogramm
haben doch verbal sehr weich spülen und
das halte ich tatsächlich für falsch und
vielleicht auch noch das thema
klimaschutz zu kommen natürlich läuft
uns die zeit davon da wird frau winter
nicht widersprechen und wahrscheinlich
ist es so dass unser technologischer
fortschritt nicht so schnell sein wird
dass wir das was wir am pariser
klimaziele erfüllen wollen mit
technologischem fortschritt erfüllen
können geschweige denn können wir ihnen
bezahlen und deshalb wird wahrscheinlich
auch gewisse einschränkungen auf die
bevölkerung zukommen beziehungsweise
muss den leuten mal näher bringen das
auch verhaltensveränderungen natürlich
dazu führen kann dass der klimaschutz
beschleunigt wird aber so lang immer
suggeriert wird für euch bleibt
eigentlich alles wie es ist alles so wie
es ist und wir machen das schon so lange
kann das auch nicht funktionieren und so
lange würde auch eine nächste regierung
keine fortschritte erzielen können also
muss einfach mehr reinen wein
einschenken und es gilt nicht nur für
den klimaschutz
es gilt auch für die rente da gibt es ja
nun nicht ganz so viele stellschrauben
arbeiten wer länger wollen wir mehr
rente bezahlen oder also mehr für den
für die beiträge zahlen oder sollen die
renten kürzer werden oder soll der
zuschuss zum bundeshaushalt ständig
steigen bei der bildung wollen wir in
den bundesländern dass jeder weiter vor
sich hin vorstellt oder soll es mehr
zentralisierung geben also es gibt so
viele themenfeldern stehen so
wegweisende entscheidungen zu treffen
sind wie gehen wir überhaupt mit der
alternden gesellschaft um die
tatsächlich teuer wird wie machen wir
das also dass da da sehe ich dass die
antworten nicht wirklich diskutiert
werden das tri l hat mal so eine ahnung
davon gegeben dass es tatsächlich genug
themen gibt die man die sich lohnen
würden ausführlich zu diskutieren und da
auch um die besten lösungen zu streiten